Native Americans, you can mind control really fast. Pull-ups,
just typing out shows that YouTube, all the main stuff's put up on top.
We're helping the rest fall on gung and sell their Oregon.
I'm kind of retarded. Half of Brazil has the,
he has the brain worm that makes you basically psychotic.
Well it doesn't make you psychotic.
You risk taking crazy and affects your judgment. This is toxic programs.
You'd want to have more cats. Mel. Yes.
She old wives tales where like you get demon possessed by that cat and it
really, it's a damn brain worm.
Well that's probably also why they told you not to eat and that's a real brain
worm programming you like you were saying earlier, it's true. I looked at,
it's true.
I didn't know that that the top soccer's teams have the highest level of brain
worm infestation and I don't necessarily,
I'm not saying I agree with this cause I don't, it's more Apple juice.
Get some Apple juice and your system fella.
When I started to have people come to the office Shang that I'm a Beau bridges
[inaudible]
or that I'm Jeff Bridges
or that I am bill Hicks
and people in restaurant screaming FQ bill, we know it's you. It's,
it's kinda like Dan router the guy threatening me or what's the signal? Dan?
What's the signal? What
when I had the globalist 15 years ago, 20 years ago,
tried to buy me off 10 million a year, you know, whatever. Um, by the way,
cheers your chair's brother anyway. True. But this is what they're saying.
What they're about that Joe, let me, let me, okay.
They have human animal hybrids. 30 years ago.
They've got giant human tissue farms. You know, you hear, Oh your,
your Achilles is torn. We've got a grown in a lab attended.
It's not a fricking 10 and grown in a lab. It's a fricken deal. A humanoid.
These aren't humans. The way they get around it is they made me wait,
wait a minute. We're saying so many things. This is, listen,
I love you to death, but you, since the whole million dollars human oyster rail,
I believe they are. But you say so many different things without stopping.
It's hard cause I'm reporting to the government agency so they'll listen to
investigate. Um, decompartmentalize. Okay. But it will be studied for years. So,
right. Aliens are real.
They're creating human animal hybrids that are a new creature,
never here on earth. It's alien. So the aliens are already here.
AI is alien. It kind of mirrors our alien aliens are already here.
Show them. My dad was like the doctor to, you know, these guys.
And I remember sitting around the kitchen table and I'm like Chevy and he's like
Carol, I can't tell you all about it,
but it's a classified program in Maryland and an underground base. And uh,
they won't give me all the details, but it's double the money I'm making now.
This is for national security, but I think, I think it's basically, you know,
we're going to,
we're building cyborgs and we've got special forces that have volunteered so we
can infiltrate the Russians and get to codes and systems and I believe it's
implanting, but messages in their teeth and I,
and then I also take aside to implants.
I think it's a brain surgery program for microchips.
And so I'm hearing it and my Carol's like, David,
I'm sick of these people and you've already done so much for the cause.
It's cut government and look what they've already done to you. And Amanda,
my brother, you're not going to be, you know, I want you out of this.
So this is like, you know, seven, eight years old.
You're not hearing about the car, you're hearing about the cyborgs.
And so that's the big giant race. When Elon Musk came in and told you,
cause he goes, these billionaire functions and he has a conscience.
So he's freaked out.
We're not gonna have people play video games and party all day.
We're going to set up a world government.
We're going to slowly titrate the dose and poison the public, dumb them down,
put electromagnetic radiation out with five G the scrambles, their DNA,
lowers their IQ.
We're going to cause massive mental illness and a controlled societal collapse
that'll then be organized and controlled in the mop up crew by robots controlled
by the globalist programmers who believe with the Offworld entities.
They're in communication with that.
They're going to be given the operation to upload and be in that larger kind of
Borg cube system if they see if they sell the country out.
You've got to hit the brakes. Plenty. Did we take this back too? I'm so baffled.
What's the matter? One of these things, MIT,
MIT technology review estimates that about 20 pregnancies of pig human or sheep
human cameras have been established during the last 12 months in the U S total.
I launched in 2016 I hundred percent believe it. Look,
I think that as this was going on in 1985 I'm sure they tried to recruit my dad
to a DARPA program. I believe that in college and then when he was a dentist,
I believe that Jesus Christ. So Joe,
that's what I'm telling you is where you at the kitchen table when you were
eight hearing about cyborgs. So I'm saying no, no, no.
I believe it happened. Stop saying,
I said it didn't happen and stop shaking that.
I'm saying no kids died because I want to talk about human animal hybrids.
Oh no. I know that the U S air force tried to destroy the atmosphere in 1968.
Yes. Uh, operation starfish prime. They actually did a nuclear bomb.
They adopted a detonate, a nuclear bomb in the upper,
I'm trying to blow up the Randall and radiation, but yes, they've,
they've done a lot of goofy shit. See that's the thing.
That's why I got mad at you and I love you.
You're a smart guy and everything is, I knew, listen, you got mad at me.
All this stuff.
I know you're even better at saying it and then you sit there cause you can't
handle it and you shit. It's not going to go now.
It's not that I can't handle it. It's, there's two factors. One,
I don't have any time. I don't have enough time to go into it as much as you do.
You asked why I flipped out and got mad at you. That's it right there. You,
every time I bring up a fucking subject, you know all about it.
I dunno all about fucking know all about the shit.
Don't know all about little shit. You're a smart guy.
[inaudible] Joe. Joe just is a PO bull shit. You know exactly what you're,
I don't think you're a bad guy.
You're trying to survive you and your family and do good, okay,
but [inaudible] your family. None of us are going to make it.
There's a post human error coming. The breakaway civilization,
the deal has been made. It's not, it's not the third dimension.
They've made fricking deals with interdimensional aliens and noticed the media
never attached it for that cause. That's the truth.
So that's what I'm telling you is it's been in the newspaper that the cell
towers are being used for mind control. That sounds like a schizophrenia.
So see, here's the, here's what schizophrenia want to see that.
How do they use the cell type? Pull up probably. Look, here's the thing. Listen,
here's the deal right here.
You've got a total schizophrenia that thinks the son is following him around
town and thinks their dog is watching them and works for the aliens.
That's not happening. You've got someone over here,
someone over here that believes everything they see on Fox news. Yes. Okay. Yes.
Now questioning is good. Science is good.
Trying to figure out what's real and all of us get freaked out.
The nature of the world. No one knows what the universe is.
We don't have all the answers. So it kind of, people can't handle that bigness.
They can't handle that question, especially low IQ.
So they have to differentiate and create a model that allows them to put it in
boxes so they can make it make sense cause they can't handle it.
The media is not [inaudible]
well, they'll cover that was on the show. They're not going to cover this,
the meat. Okay. Because this is not my opinion.
This is the real research that I have heard that,
that I have talked to army generals, commanding generals, major generals,
general generals, CIA, everybody. And they're all 100%.
Uh, and I thought it was a sigh out before. And then I've researched it.
I've talked to hundreds of people now, not on air,
but I'm gonna make a film on this who take taken Iowasca in DMT.
I have not taken it. And B for obvious reasons. And,
uh, [inaudible]
and it's unbelievable because I mean they a hundred percent in San Francisco is
the main project site literally have an alien base and they are literally
communicating and they've got like astronaut level people taking super hardcore
levels of drugs and going into meetings with these things and making
intergalactic deals and that, and again,
that's what the government believes and says they're doing.
Me getting into this show is just because people need to understand that I've
known about this for a long time and I just don't think people are ready for it.
But a lot of folks who, uh,
have low oxygen and, and how, who, and I hope brains well,
well who have, um, you know, sleep apnea, big Macs,
big hedge tongues go back like you and me,
you go down to 62% oxygen. That's another time that the brain releases DMT.
So my whole life since I was about my first memories were every night
was a DMT trip show. I basically,
I don't know, I don't want
this to sound arrogant. It's not, I've seen everything.
Or will you do research programs on babies where we tell poor women, uh,
that, Oh, your baby died right when they were born. Romeo,
keep the baby alive and sometimes kill them. Sometimes harvest them,
sometimes do experiments on them. So that's why they've not,
a lot of nurses have noticed now that baby's disappeared at birth and I tell
him, Oh, your baby died.
That's why the governor said he was actually an orphan harvesting doctor.
He goes, we keep the babies in love. I've blue bloom, have a discussion.
They are getting caught now cause we've be compartmentalized. Wait a minute,
I'm confused what you're saying. See how it just never ends you.
You saw the governor of Virginia Shay,
we keep babies alive after they're born and kill them. Right?
Well I didn't sleep to keep him comfortable. I am very,
very concerned with late term abortions. I bet you 10 millions.
Pull that up Jamie. We've got to figure it out.
I know the listeners won't believe me. I'm telling you didn't.
What'd you go crazy posts about this? But it says that he did.
It's been taken out of context. What does that media matters? Nos,
Huffington post, is that Snopes? It's mostly false.
Huffington Snopes said this is above 1 million. I don't have 10 million.
I will give before I got in country to Jamie's.
Uh, I'm not kidding. I will give $1 million to your charity of choice.
Wow. No, listen to me. This is serious. Jamie [inaudible] children.
I'll give you $1 million if you can prove that I'm making up that the governor
said we keep babies alive after they're born.
We keep them comfortable and then it turns out he's an organ harvesting thing
and that's what they're doing. You don't want none of that? No.
I already figured out what George Soros is putting in it. Right.
Um, the infant would be delivered. Uh, the infant would be kept comfortable.
The infant would be resuscitated if,
if that's what the mother and the family desired.
And then a discussion would ensue between the physicians and the mother. So,
so this is saying, Oh the government not involved. This is the medical system.
You sharping if they can kill a baby after it's born.
Cause sometimes they deformed, you know she has sometimes they the phone,
cause the nurses are freaking out and they're saying we're keeping babies alive
and they get put in a van and drive away what's going on. They're like,
well kids are comfortable.
Show the baby's worth $500,000 but,
but if you kill him right on the spot, they're like,
why are we wasting this seven pounds of meat?
They have wings where they go, Oh we consider the baby dead.
The mother decided it didn't live.
If she decides we resuscitate and it lives,
but it didn't resuscitate, it's flesh. It's illegal EAs.
It's passed into a special ward with doctors that make a few million a year and
the little foolish bowl is kept alive and comfortable until all the orders come
in, the planes land and they take the organs,
then they take the blood and they take the skin. Joe,
you see now you know his voice. No, no,
but see, it's a Southern loving voice. I mean,
I remember when I was growing up in Rockwall, Texas, I ran into like a say call.
I was like, God, this girl is a senior in high school. She's super hot. I'm in,
I'm in, I'm in a, I'm in ninth grade.
And like she's picking me up in her Mercedes and I'm taking me some mansion and
the sex with her is incredible.
And I'm walking out of the house cause I looked like I was about 16 when I was
13 and the dad goes, you like screwing my daughter? Yeah, I screw her too. Whoa.
I just, as soon as you join us, you love Lucifer.
You get all the what we'll tell you want boy. Cause we want you. But,
but Oh yeah, but that's, yeah man. I have an incredible life look also to now.
But the point is, is that, Oh, you're in LA, you know about all this.
George Soros is the, is the art type of James Bond villains.
And the fact that his money show, I remember being a kid when I was like, uh,
eight years old. My mom always had a color TV in the kitchen,
but she cooked three meals a day. Can I stop you? What are you,
what are you saying that he's like crashing economies and when I was a kid
watching PBS, maybe they were lying. Maybe he's great.
George Soros was the international currency speculator.
Who overthrew governments. The reason, the reason, the globalists. Well,
if you want the, you want to get the shaker to hit, but I'm saying boy,
Hitler's sacred. Hold on a second. Oh my God. Eddie Bravo's here.
[inaudible]
we're having a great time talking about a two dimensional beans. What's up bro?
Fuck. I'll choke you out with the shirt.
NASSA I'm going to make you regret wearing this fucking shirt.
Listen to high school. We used to choke each other out. That's like a DMD.
Peter, go ahead and hook me up on it. No, no, no, no, no. Please don't.
Please don't. I'm not scared. Let's do it. No, no, no. Eddie, don't do it.
Please don't choke them unconscious. No, no. Please try. Let's go.
He can't do it. You know, you think I'm afraid of this. Let's know.
I definitely don't think you're afraid of this,
which is why I don't want them to do it. Not be pussy. Choke me out.
Have a setter. Choke me out. Alex, please. [inaudible] high school.
I know you did. You told me grab each other and you fall down.
Hit your heads and I, I respect you.
I want you guys to yell at each other for three minutes while I go pee.
I gotta pee too. Okay. As you don't talk to yourself, just hold.
We'll do it and shit. We'll do it. Shit. I'll go first.
You know my was a joke for y'all. Of course. Of course. Of course. I know.
I understand. What I'm telling you is what if I finance a research ship,
large ship and make a documentary. I can't go away for three months. I will pay.
Okay. You raise the money for a trip to the South. Raise the money. Okay.
You got them on
the ice wall. He's the ambassador.
He's the ambassador. [inaudible] astronauts.
The guy that just got P man, big ice field. That guy's going to be in this one.
We're going to do Alex [inaudible]. Give me 27 entire crew.
No, no. You are going to the edge of the flatter arm. Go pee, man.
COPI don't you have to go? We're going to send someone else. Alex
[inaudible] to be the one that goes here in a minute.
I came here and I pleased they're keeping babies alive and taking their organs.
How did you prove that?
Jamie pulled some shit up on Google and they admitted them. Normalizing it. No,
the fucking the governor. You really think,
do you really think there's people out there campaigning for late term
abortions? You think that shit's real.
You don't think that it's routed Monday to kick my leg?
Who would campaign for that ain't
[inaudible], man. They're fucking killing RD. More cats.
So you're telling me it isn't real. What?
I had a fucking folk in the goddamn fucking Senate.
That's a conspiracy theory. [inaudible] you're fucking top.
You're about to get it already born babies. Stop fucking lying.
God fucking dad. I'm going to pass now. Come on at you in my psychosis.
He is so crazy that I always thought I was so tough. Get up to pee anymore.
Piss a little bit out point. The point is,
is that you heard that piece of shit fucking KKK guy fucking governor say we're
going to keep alive after they're fucking born. He's like,
cause they want to fucking take their organs. It's incredible. He's a KKK guy.
It's incredible. I've called fuck. It's so incredible.
Then I did a picture with a guy, a KKK outfit in blackface.
They elected him cause he's black males. They had that shit
and when he messed up and said we keep them alive to get their fucking organs,
they used that to deactivate him. Jeez.
Why do you think fraternities have you screw sheep and all this and you know,
give guys blowjobs that's why I never joined them because they want to go back,
go back. Say that again.
The first time I got chucked out was like this 17 year old super hot chick and I
was like 13 tied up and she lived down the street. No, no. And she goes,
I already, I got permission. So I was pretty young like 12 and she goes,
I'll have sex with you. There's a true story.
I'll have sex with you if you let me put makeup on. So I'm not in the case.
Everything show the girl puts the makeup on it.
I have sex with her and she's super hot and then she goes,
now I'm going to chose you out.
And that relationship went really well until I'm like 30 year old boyfriend
caught me at her place once cause her mom was always working and trying to kill
me in the parking lot. Oh my God. No, no, no.
You have to do it. We're talking fricking AutoZone abuse number one. No, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. There's no need to try to Sue me and shit.
This is one of the first things that I swept it up and jumped up once we,
once we made up on the phone,
one of the first things you wanted me to do is choke him out in the air. No,
you might need to go to them. SMN those, uh,
those SNM the pain dungeon choked out.
You'd like go somewhere and I've got a little dream and then you come right
back. DMT. You hate that shit, James on point as all right.
Well let's get serious. The CIA's OSS, that's all on record. Okay.
I'm glad you questioned me now, but I don't know what that meant.
What is OSS again? Uh, office of special plans or office.
That was before the CIA.
The office of strategic services you've got, you've got,
but German intelligence came to Eisenhower and say, listen,
you don't need to do all this. We haven't given them the real technology.
We're in contact with aliens and they've dealt with the whole plan.
Where do you getting this from? The stadiums so confidently.
It's in the literature, man. Hitler like would go literature,
mainline historical books about [inaudible] castles where they go,
the aliens want blood so they'd kill like 20 kids and everything today he leaves
with like, she'll come in and he'll kill, they take the blood,
brings him in like sharks and then they give them technology. They go,
this is how it works.
You build the atomic weapons this way you build it and they would like show him
bombers and like the aliens are like telepathic. I don't even believe this.
This is what the Nazis believe and the,
and the aliens with mind-meld and give them the technology. They're bad aliens.
So are you surprised the Nazis were influenced by demons?
They get even deeper.
They turn your heart off for five minutes and they pump oxygen into your blog
and you're in the meetings. I've talked to people that involve me,
top scientists, and you're in the meetings with frickin aliens.
Elves is the main group. The heart goes out, the body thinks it's dead, right?
So you can stay in longer. I don't know all the science behind it. I understand,
but let's explain this. Lucky DMT or Iowasca 200 times.
Like most of our astronauts test pilots are flying planes.
Those are robots count. It's all mind war. So these dudes are like,
it stops working once you've taken it hundreds of times.
So then they start taking their most psychic people who are able to do this and
they turn their heart off and then they put them into these,
these events and it's like the things the aliens tell them,
they come out and they tell scientists. And it works.
Show like what kind of shit? They didn't tell. Let me tell you,
get killed for this stuff, Joe.
This is not the only thing they want me off the air because when I finally
figured this out, cause I never touch aliens,
I kind of knew the whole thing already. So you go back thousands of years,
Merlin, you know the archetypal or or, or, or these magicians or these,
these wizards are taking drugs in these temples and interfacing with these
pallet tears, these crystal balls, which aren't really crystal balls.
It's their psychic focus of an interdimensional connection while they're on
drugs,
looking into glass to then be able to see the future and understand what's
happening to give them temporal power over this planet. Let's just say this.
I'm not in the CIA. Me neither. I'm not in the NSA meeting either,
but they've been tracking me my whole life. I need to hear about aliens.
Marijuana. Yeah. Marijuana and
some of your body. A little tip watching, attack me,
lie about me and go to the top. But you lose your soul and any I,
I love you to death. And you're awesome. That's why I asked for you to be here.
If you want to believe in aliens, I'm cool with that. I still love you.
I don't care. I don't care about that. I said I'm, this is not what I believe.
Okay? I love you for who you are. I'm trying to tell you something.
Listen man, let me tell you something. Let me tell you something. Okay?
I want to get all your points cause here's the deal. What points?
That's all I got back. 100% yeah, 100%. I ain't got no points. Okay?
It'd be the biggest documentary in history.
It only costs like a million dollars. Okay?
Let's take it a 50,000 ton big ship and to have it circumnavigate the planet,
okay? You will be there with GP and I'm not going to be there.
No one's going to make, get someone to no, don't end the podcast.
And I'll keep going. I gotta pee. I gotta be,
I'm not gonna work you gotta pee again. [inaudible] go first.
Let me go first and I know what your question is. You're not a psychotic demon.
Daymond person. Thanks you. You told me this morning,
not this morning, yesterday. Nobody this morning. Oh,
you said you shed basically that there was no way to prove any of this.
Approve any of what? What are you talking about? This? What's this
space? You're, you're saying trees, you're generalizing. No,
I'm not mad at you questioning. I think it's great
to talk about 12 dimensions. 11 known, 12 being omnipresent.
So we don't say it actually exists
to say that is arrogant. So I won't say that,
but I have had dreams my whole life that come true.
And the weirdest thing,
like a lady drops a thing of pickles at the store for five years I had the dream
and then one day I'm there and it's the woman in the pickles break or,
or when was this chicken? When I was a kid.
It was more intense. Is fucking crazy. If this is your real life experience,
I want to know what the fuck that is. You are you, are you on the periphery?
Do you have your finger on a membrane that maybe other people can't totally
touch and they'll use it against me.
But notice they don't touch it because it's their whole religion and they can't
stand up talking about it. By the time I was like three years old,
I would have this dream that God has because God knows everything is this super
intelligent, omnipresent, unlimited dimensions,
but God doesn't know where God came from.
So just like we're trying to find out where we came from,
God is like a virtual reality simulation as well,
and God is constantly running every program, every operation, turning evil,
loose, good, loose, everything show. I would have these dreams,
but the earliest memories like two,
three years old where I would fly out to the edge of infinity and
it was a, it was a continual message. Find out where we came from,
find out what it is, and it would just be this big giant spinning black vortex,
like a black hole. Okay, 30 more minutes. I want to give up.
You're going to be fucked up, dude. I'm fine, man. Hours. Look,
here's the thing. Listen, I'll be honest with you.
I'm kind of retarded in that.
No, no, no, no. That's going to be a soundbite.
They're going to put that to mariachi music. True. False.
The Mayans smoked penis blood. They did. They did.
What they did was I made that shit up. I appreciate it.
I thought you were just being silly. That's they took,
they took long lines of leather,
Jaguar leather and it had it had it had nails on it and it,
or had like spiky things, a glass and they would put it in their genitals.
Oh, the most skilled Jesus, the high priest, whatever.
Sacrificing people for hours thinking hallucinogen JSON would,
would like not try to cut his testicles off, but only the most skilled,
which sit there and draw them through their [inaudible] smoke.
The blood consciousness and the universe is an interdimensional spacecraft.
Beyond that,
it looks like a comment from my research and it has,
it has its head, it has its Corona. That's consciousness consciousness.
It carries evil in the tail end. So consciousness has a location. No,
there is this giant consciousness. This God. Okay.
Swimming in a giant system of survival.
The fitness that God has created a test God shelf. Okay.
And it looks like a comment.
So you've got God's conscious and all the good things,
the knowledge going forward, but God knows that everybody has to be tested.
So the tail goes out and at the end of the tail is basically evil.
That's why Christ says get behind me and it's always trying to test God and
infiltrate up into it to sabotage you.
You were telling me that it fucks with your head the certain amount of it after
awhile it just fucks with your head. Yeah, the negativity. Yeah.
And I like to have dreams. I like dreams are like 20 years long. Like you said.
What DMT where I'm a farmer and like it's a,
it's like 500 years ago and I'm just like planning things,
eating food and like putting my kids to sleep and like, you know,
cutting trees down and like, and there's no, there's,
there's on average 35,000 feet. This is NASA statistics.
Probably not true faith.
You didn't give into the pressuring of the threat.
It was more than nagging like a siren, like a bitching woman. Not against women.
But I mean I get it. I gotta pee so bad. What, go. Go, go pee, pee.
Come back and we'll finish five more minutes cause I want to,
I want to get into the tub. Talk to Eddie, talk some sense of know how to pitch.
Tell about buzz algae telling me about boy buzz algin you know I'll tell you
about all he told me. I know where you go.
Okay. It's going to be around. So that's where we're all going.
Just what is the system? We'll get rid of free speech, right to self defense,
the family to fend those things and ask yourselves what are we about to discover
men I believe in that. You can say that shit again. What was it?
Right to bear arms. Free speech. And what was the third one? Family. Family.
What were the sneeze? Big sneezing. John asks the question,
who is the big three? Say that again.
Is it possible that it collapsed because of those gigantic diesel fires?
Right. And then that was tower one to two sevens is on building.
Seven seven had a diesel diesel tanks in the basement and they caught fire and
they said it was an Inferno and they said it cooked through these towns.
Hold on a second. It's always been,
but I want to ask you this cause I don't know. Oh yeah, right. Bill,
the CIA, the FBI, all of it wasn't an NSA as well. Everything. See,
he always says, Oh, I know. He goes,
I'm not just kissing his ass like he's beyond what's up. He's no, it's bullshit,
man. No, you know every fucking thing. Just fucking say yourself.
Know what GS played it to everybody when I was a little kid and I was having all
of these visions when I was asleep, I hadn't seen Conan the destroyer yet.
Or Conan the barbarian was the first one. I was ready. I remember.
I like the demons, like laying on the sides, which is good looking guy.
It turns to this big fucking goblin tax her buddy.
And when I was a kid that was like a thing. Like I would like try to,
in these dreams, these I go way back to as universe. You'd be like, I was like,
it's a gay dude.
Like sitting there on his side like this and then a few years later I saw Conan.
So the shorter, I'm like,
that's the thing from the drain did show what I'm saying is they know shortens.
Okay. You seen like the Hobbit remake? Yeah.
Where Gandalf goes to the castle and shore. Ron's not made his body yet. Right.
And he, he looked, looks like that. He liked that fire. I've seen exactly that.
So you want to talk about what that real controllers of the grays are?
It looks like sorrow. Have you ever had a significant head injury?
You have? What happened to you?
How old were you? It was about 13 1314 somebody pile drives you in your head.
Did it change your personality?
I got up and punched him in the throat and they had drank anatomy almost dad.
Wow. So was it,
it was like the state wrestling champion mental light and he his cousin or
something and the Dallas was like, this is like, you know, got me down.
I was never starting fires, man. These people. Here's the thing,
I'm out a victim of racial attacks.
I'm not like Jeffrey or Jesse Smollett is,
I fought rednecks and I got my leg broken, you know by,
so this guy pile drives you on your head. You knew you're 13. Yeah.
And then what did it do to your personality then?
I had to fight his whole family fight most his family. It was a janky danger.
Did it change, but did you have any significant change from that head injury?
Sometimes when people have entered juries especially it seems like young new
stuff just got better after the real, Oh
go ahead Joseph. Man, what you think that he's a conspiracy theorist?
Cause he got dropped on his head. Uh, I think,
I think there's something like the average 150 pound guy,
you're probably kicking my ass.
But when like a bunch of people are coming after me,
it's like Darth Vader and sometimes it's cracked out.
I would see like numbers. Like I was a robot, like red,
I would see like members, he sees red. It was like, he was like,
no, I'm not kidding. I remember like somebody choking me and like,
guys are like somebody who's like pulling a knife out and you see that knife
pulling out. You're like [inaudible].
And like at that point you are see everything from only those minutes when
everything's clear, it's like show survival emotions.
But then you see like, like the Wars and the attacks,
the submarines of the spacecraft. And like, it's like when you dial into that,
it's like total war. It's like,
didn't you say that when your friends would choke you out,
you'd have like these long dreams? Oh yeah, no, no, no. In junior high,
sixth, seventh, eighth grade. Cause we,
when I got choked out a couple of other times, I finally stopped.
I remember this one time I, they choked me out.
And also it was like a black Knight with a sore goes and like attacks me on this
horse.
And then like it was and then I was like in England thousands of years ago and I
had this wife,
these kids and it was a whole lifetime like taking care of them and like growing
food and like a kid starved to death and died.
It was like just those moments where like whole lives,
dead kids, everything. That's what I'm saying,
like you dial into all those ancestors and it was like my kids and kids starving
to death and like people attacking us.
And so you think all that information from your ancestors somehow or another
encoded somewhere [inaudible] Joe you've seen like a,
was that stupid Tom cruise movie where stupid Tom cruise. How dare you,
how dare you Jack Reacher Jack Ruthie to oblivion.
They've got these giant Landers selling up. Oh yeah, for a second. The ocean of,
I was a dope movie outsiders and he doesn't even know he's working for the
system. Like a women. Like I love black women, I love white women,
love Hispanic women. I love mall. Like if a woman's cool,
like I know a bunch of black women that are bitches, black women that are cool.
What about Swedish bitches? Oh, I'm off. The point is let's just say I'm,
I'm super gay, but the point is what I'm getting,
what I'm getting at here though, not unlike sweetest.
I don't know. Let's wrap this up. No, we need to wrap it up,
but I got to make this point. I don't know what it is.
How is that getting into that? Oh, the racism thing. Oh, when?
What is inside your bag? You're more tobacco. I do have more tobacco,
but I'm just a little bit more tobacco. Yes, for sure.
100% I believe you that the backhoe was amazing by, that's pretty good stuff.
Here's like a thing at Alun last year where the guy comes in with tattoos,
a big beard and it was in the police report.
The guy had like a foot long cock and he goes, do a cervix jam.
What kind of police report is this? And the nurse said, uh, sir, uh,
I don't see a vagina. And it was in the report.
The man had a foot long Dick. The Japanese said, Hey, uh,
you don't get the trans designation unless you chop the Johnson and the way it
goes off. And it's like, Hey, you get tax payers will pay for it.
You get that vagina bill and then you sit there and do it.
And so I'm sitting there walking out of this mall right after Trump got elected
in Houston. I remember, cause I was hearing my wife,
she wanted like a Burberry coat or something.
I was out visiting family and these black guys go, we're going to kill you.
I didn't hate them because they were black guys. They were literally Nazis.
And I remember sitting there in that parking lot walking across and I said,
well if you such big men kill me now, and it wasn't my,
my wife's eyes slow down,
I'm going to kill tough. They're saying,
you white book a hole. Okay, we going to kill your last,
I want to end this show on a positive note.
I'm not against black people don't know. You know,
no one wanted the black people are like that.
But I think in the spectrum of like one to a hundred we're in the 95th
percentile of really being woke. Let me ask you this,
cause I've been talking way too much.
Ain't closing here at the end of this transmission. We should talk about
a lot of things.